down by the court today is a reflection
of the seriousness of his crimes
i hope that knowing he will now spend
many years behind bars this will bring a
small degree of comfort to bieber and
nicole's loved ones
this has been a shocking and chilling
case and i know the investigation will
stay with all of us involved for a very
long time
daniel hussain went out that night with
the intention of killing in order to
satisfy his bizarre fantasies under the
deluded belief he would be rewarded with
financial prosperity
his wicked acts have cut short the lives
of two completely innocent women who
were simply celebrating her birthday
bieber's birthday
the senselessness of hussein's actions
has made it all the more difficult for
bieber and nicole's loved ones to come
to terms with their loss
despite this throughout our
investigation subsequent trial they've
shown the utmost dignity and strength in
the most unimaginable of circumstances
my thoughts and those of my colleagues
are always with them thank you
i think you've heard me say in the past
there'll be no celebrations here
but justice has been done but i think we
do need to review
that kind of separation when is someone
an adult
and i think it's very disrespectful to
say that children
can't tell the difference between good
and evil
so
that's something else i will be
campaigning about
but today we are celebrating what is
wonderful about the metropolitan police
i've never been one to cast a whole
organization by
one particular
sort of incident
but we do have a problem
we do have an underground that has
infiltrated and growing in our met
police
but once again i want to say thank you
to this team
that worked tirelessly to find the
killer
the hours that they put in
and you know when someone's just doing a
job and when they're invested
while so many people have become
invested in this story
and i want to thank the media
you're finally getting our story your
son you're understanding
why
everybody's important
and you're not falling into the trap of
highlighting one story against another
everybody is worth
knowing about
and sadly i've had lots of requests for
interviews but the last few weeks have
been extremely difficult for me they
have triggered
my ailments which is cfs and
fibromyalgia
and what happens is your brain doesn't
work how it should do
and so i only want to speak
when i feel i can do it justice
but thank you all for being here and
caring and get the message out to your
bosses
when you interview someone for an hour
and they only put it on for two minutes
they're saying something very bad about
the importance and the significance of
those people
and whether they're on the front page
the middle page or the back page you you
put a precedent on who is more important
everyone's important
don't make that mistake
because when i feel better i'm coming
for you
thank you
oh
you know um
they were beautiful beautiful girls to
look at anyway
but they had real they were real people
with hearts
bieber has left behind a daughter
who has given birth to a son in the last
year be coming up for a year
and i'm a great grandmother
and i only met him because of kovid i
only met him for the first time at the
celebration of life so life is going on
there is a legacy
and nicole i i think we grieve more for
her because
there was
20 years difference
she had 20 years less than bieber
but
to know her was to love her
and
there's so much more i'm going to share
with you
and you can see her in action
and lots and lots of families
have given tribute to bieber because she
was an amazing social worker who was
able to drill down
and and do the difference between
there could never be cover-ups
she wanted to see the kids she wanted to
know if there was food there she wanted
to know whether they were really on it
but she would never take her child away
unless
she tried everything
so
good girls i'm really really proud of
them mina can you just share with us
your thoughts about daniel
today
do you know do you know what
um
it's all a performance
you know i taught secondary kids
for 20 years 15 of those were all boys
there's nothing you can't tell me about
men and boys
and that is a performance designed to i
don't know elicit
sympathy or to have us believe that
there's something really wrong with him
there's nothing wrong with him
he's just an obnoxious
human being and at one point there was a
screen in front of us and it was a tiny
bit we could only see a tiny and the
clark said would you like us to we can
make that bigger bigger picture
i said no thank you
we don't actually need to see him
he's a broken human being
who
if he hadn't been caught
four other families
may have been suffering what we have
well he ain't out there now
and i think he is so deluded
come 35 years time
they won't give him they won't let him
out
they won't let him out
i won't let them let them out
thank you
thank you thank you